[Music]
blake by his own admission gave away
hundreds of british agents
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
frances foster
i'm constantly kissing and this is a
show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is a
journalist for the financial times
and now the author of the happy traitor
simon cooper welcome to trigonometry
it's an honest to be here this is the
very first interview i've done in
english about this book
and i did not know that you two existed
apart from kilconomics the festival
where i always meet you
so it's great to see that you are real
people thank you very much
er there are a lot of people who think
we're controlled opposition and avatars
created by the government
so yes we do exist jewish shills and
there's all sorts of other options uh
whatever you decide of the political
spectrum you hate us from
uh but enough about us i mean you've
written a brilliant book i've always
enjoyed your commentary anyway
uh you've written about football quite a
lot and about many other subjects but
the happy traitor is is a biography of
george blake the double agent
uh before we get into that uh
tell everybody a little bit about who
you are how are you where you are what
was your interest in writing this book
um and so on well
i spent most of my life writing for the
financial times i used to write sports
stuff and i write political and cultural
stuff about
how the world is coming to an end as we
all know
and i am quite an international person
like you constantin and i grew up mostly
in the netherlands by chance my dad had
a job there and
so about 20 years ago i read an article
in in holland about this kgb agent
who was british dutch in origin he'd
grown up in holland
british egyptian jewish father and he
had ended up
george blake a kgb agent jailed in
bristol and escaped to moscow and i
thought what an amazing story that was
the first i heard
i must interview this guy one day
because i grew up about 20 miles away
from him
in the netherlands uh also jewish also
british
also speaking dutch as he did so
egoistically i saw a lot of similarities
between me and blake
and then in 2012 i was going to speak at
a conference in moscow
and i have a dutch friend in moscow who
knows blake he knew blake
and i said would you set me up with
blake and you know
the story goes on and i could bang on
about that but
in the end i'm sitting in blake stature
listening to this story
i mean i was the deal was it was
complicated to arrange it with blake as
you can imagine
kgb double agents are not always keen to
go on the record etc
so blake actually phoned me to interview
me first and i was
in this moscow cemetery i was looking at
the graves of
chekhov and khrushchev i can't remember
the name of the cemeteries well-known
one in moscow
and blake calls me and he speaks in his
very old-fashioned sort of
pre-war.jackson we have a nice chat
and his issue which he doesn't dare
express is he doesn't want me to ask him
about putin because he's very afraid of
putin he
he hates putin he thinks putin is
anti-democratic et cetera but he
relies on putin on his pension and his
dacha
and so i say look you know mr blake i'm
not gonna i won't ask you about boosting
i want to ask you about your life etc
so he says come on over and uh we had a
lovely time together actually i have to
admit i
really like the guy which is something i
had to wean myself off in the later
writing
and i walked out of his dutch after four
hours thinking
i was only going to write an interview
for a dutch newspaper
he only wanted me to write about it in
dutch and
i walked out thinking that was the most
interesting interview i've ever done in
my journalistic career
wow but my kids were quite small at the
time so i never had a free moment to
myself so only a couple of years later
did i think actually you know i'm no
longer in the playground
every hour of the weekend i could think
about turning this interview into a book
so then i began to research his life
and if the book is a happy traitor uh
with beau freda it is
absolutely brilliant he did lead a
fascinating life
why do you think it was that for someone
who was actually a very very
mild-mannered man
he then went and had this career where
he became a double agent
risking his life and also ending many
others
i mean he says himself that to be a spy
you have to kind of like the game the
secrecy
the adventure and you know he was
always into kind of dressing up and
acting i mean even as a child with his
sisters he'd act the pastor his ambition
was to be a covenant pest
pastor he would act hitler uh who was of
course big figure on the world stage in
his childhood
and he liked the thrill so when he's
17 18 world war ii breaks out and he's
in the netherlands having spent a few
years with family in cairo
and he joins the dutch resistance as a
teenage courier
and he has very exciting times but he
thinks i want the big stage
and also i want to join my mummy in
england she'd fled to england when the
war broke out
he was very much a mummy's boy and so he
escaped
through belgium and france and franco
spain
amazing journey in 1942-43 underground
through occupied europe to britain
where he does indeed join the british
secret services so he'd always had this
kind of yen for adventure for the double
life
uh behind this mild-mannered facade
but he was also an idealist i mean he
starts off with this very pious
calvinist and he then becomes
a very pious communist mm-hmm well
actually this was what i was going to
ask you about because
my impression and correct me if i'm
wrong from from the book is that
by the time he joins the british secret
service he's already
a committed communist is that correct
that's not what i
believe some people have suggested that
i don't think so i think
in his youth into his 20s he's a
culverist
in the war he still thinks well after
the war i'm going to become a pastor
and he's very anti-nazi auntie hitler
he's a
half-jewish briton living in the
occupied netherlands so he
he very courageously takes the side of
the resistance which very few dutch
people did
and he gets to london and his focus is
on
winning the war he's not really a
british patriot never pretended to be
but he
you know he's part of the dutch effort
to win the war
and it's only later when the
when mi6 sis is it then was the secret
intelligence service send him to
south korea as a spy the korean war
breaks out in 1950
he is held captive by the north koreans
for two years
with other british and french prisoners
and in that time the almost the only
reading matter they have sent
is marx and lenin in russian so marx and
russian translation sounds like a modern
university campus
it is like distance learning it's true
yes so you got the good [ __ ] in the
original language
yeah well he he um
he could have read marks in german as
well and blake was very much languages
man
but he'd learned russian in a year in
cambridge he wasn't
there with kim philby at all he was
there in 1947 48 but he goes to
cambridge he learns russian he loves the
language
within months he can read anna karenina
in the original and so when
he's in captivity i mean they had
nothing to do for two years a group of
highly intelligent men
and at one point the soviet embassy sent
them this package of books they're very
excited but there's only one book in
english
treasure island by stevenson so they
think okay well who gets to read
treasure island first this is going to
be the biggest thrill
of of our lives here so they draw lots
and so they read stevenson in turn and
they just keep re-reading it and in the
end the copy is
destroyed and they're two books in
russian marx and lennon
and so blake and the former british
council in careers an old british
conservative
read marx in russian discuss it and the
consul says to blake you know i'm an
anti-communist
but i believe that marx is correct that
communism is the future
it will replace the british empire and
um
i i'm sorry to say that i think
communism is going to win and blake was
very persuaded by this
and but we talk about so i mean his
ideological indoctrination you might say
at this particular point
but the seeds of his belief in communism
was sold much earlier
in his time in egypt with the disparity
between rich and poor that he observed
there were many forces pushing him i
mean when his father dies
they get a letter from the father's
sister in cairo and she says well
um my brother you probably didn't know
it he was jewish that was a huge shock
to blake's family
never knew the father was jewish anyway
uh
you must be quite poor now that your
husband has died she writes to blake's
mother so come and live in our mansion
in cairo and i've seen pictures it's an
amazing mansion it's now the algerian
embassy
so blake lives in this fantastic
opulence in
uh cairo which was then a kind of
european run city and
he lives in this jewish family they
speak french and
they are the richest people in the world
and around them
the average age of death for egyptians
is about 30. i mean it's
the circumstances are terrible the
family has a kind of
textile uh mill on the nile where the
workers
children are treated terribly and so
that i think was definitely something
that worked on blake that he thought
well you know
the world is unjust but he had grown up
believing that
communism was the enemy of god and so
these influences work on him a bit the
british secret service
fatally give him this book which they've
written a guy called karoo hunt had
written a book for the british spy
service called theory and practice of
communism
the idea being you know communism is the
new enemy post war so we have to
understand communism what it is
and so kuru hunt very kind of honestly
and fairly tries to describe communism
meaning
you know this is what we're up against
chaps but blake reads his book and
thinks wow that's very convincing
communism sounds just the thing and so
all these influences work on him
he falls in love with russia and with
russian again toured by a very
anti-communist uh
russian british exile at cambridge and
so when
he starts to read marx in 1950 all these
influences have come together
he's lost his faith in god he also
believes very strongly in uh
determinism everything we do in life is
determined
uh god shapes all our actions and the
communists of course have a version of
that which is history is determined
there's nothing really the individual
can do about it so he's very much kind
of equipped for communism when he meets
it head-on in korea
and once then that happens and he goes
back to the uk where was the moment
where he actually started to defect and
start to work for the kgb
and the soviets that happens in in north
korea
i mean it's not quite clear exactly who
chats up who
he says at one point he slipped a note
to the north korean camp commander who
the prisoners called fatso
so he gives this note to fatso in
russian disgusting
bigotry and fat shaming i can't believe
in 1950 they didn't ah
unbelievable anyway sorry sam carry on i
think the prisoners were quite thin at
that point
very privileged
[Laughter]
they were privileged members not at a
very privileged moments of their lives
and so at that point a kgb agent from
vladivostok shows up a guy called um
nikolai no
lanco and lanka
uh interrogates all the prisoners and he
and blake kind of recognize kindred
spirits in each other
and so lanka says to blake you know you
could be a kgb spy
and so in 1953 stalin dies immediately
there's a big thaw and the prisoners are
happily released
they go straight to china where they all
have a big bath together and they sing
nursery rhymes
they're elated they're given new suits
and
in spring 1953 blake arrives back in
britain he and the other british
prisoners given a hero's welcome at raf
abingdon airport and he goes
back to the sis and says hi guys here i
am and they say wow you're the hero of
north korea you survived communist
captivity
and weirdly i mean just two years before
guy burgess and donald mclean had
defected
to moscow so and kim philby was under
suspicion
so mi6 knew you know there are some
some bad eggs around here and yet
it doesn't seem to have occurred to
anyone to
check out blake to see whether he might
have been turned in north korean
captivity they just say
welcome back george you know come
straight in that's really interesting
isn't it simon because as you'll know
you know and i obviously know having
grown up in russia and the soviet union
that was not the way that returning
heroes were treated in the soviet union
if you came back from abroad having been
held in captivity you'd go straight into
a gulag and be interrogated and then
make very sure that you weren't an enemy
spy but that didn't happen
and by this point he's already been
turned so he goes back into mi6
and at this point he starts being a
double agent is that right
he starts being a double agent so he
walks around with this camera strapped
between his legs every day at work a
little minox camera
and at lunch all the other spies go to
their clubs on some james's and you know
big lunches as posh people did in the
50s
and he um photographs all the documents
and then he meets his uh kgb handlers
on you know the top flights of buses in
the london fog on corners in belsius
park
deserted surrey railway stations and he
hands them all these documents
and they really like it and he tells
them that the
uh the alli the western allies usuk have
built a spy tunnel under berlin
to listen to soviet telephone calls so
he blows the berlin spy tunnel even
before it goes into operation which is
the kind of main
western listening device of the 50s and
so yeah he's giving the soviets amazing
stuff and he is never suspected
because in many ways he was actually i
mean
take aside the fact that you know he
sent hundreds of people probably to
their deaths
in many ways he was a perfect employee
wasn't he
yeah i mean he was uh he was a very
smart guy and john mccarray who was
obsessed by him
who also kindly uh offered a quote for
the book
because he lecarry read the manuscripts
before he died
le carre says look if you're a double
agent you want to make a very good
impression on your own service so that
you know you get promoted you get good
jobs
uh nobody gives you a hard time
so blake worked very well in a way for
britain and he was
he was good kind of spying material
because he wasn't easily blackmailable
he didn't drink he didn't have affairs
he had a very kind of dull family life
he wasn't gay either that was another
one
he wasn't gay although you know the
british upper class was
was more flexible on that of course than
later generations say so ever burgess
continued
burgess and blood continued to be gay
into adulthood because the ex
the system in the british upper class
was you so more or less had to be gay
until you finished university and then
you were supposed to
marry and go straight and that was
considered entirely
um non-blackmailable i mean you didn't
really say oh this chap had
homosexual affairs at cambridge because
of course
that was the requirement no not
after university which was seen as
eccentric but not as particularly
reprehensible i think
oh god i miss the good old days he went
to boarding school i did
uh but simon so he he he's not easily
blackmaidable he's the model
employee uh and just i mean we're
talking about it very jobly of course
but i
i think we should also do do justice to
what you might describe
i think quite accurately as this man's
terrible crimes
can you sum up for us the scale of the
damage he did
to british and western
uh efforts to defeat the soviet union
and also
you know the lives of the many agents
that were taken as a result of his
betrayal
well let's start with the agents i mean
when the brits finally
um unmasked him in 1961
they do this survey of their uh foreign
spying stations mostly in eastern europe
and they reckon that blake by his own
admission gave away
hundreds of british agents so if you
were let's say
a telephone operator
in moscow passing information on to
britain
blake given the soviets your name or any
spelling
if you were a businessman um
from let's say britain who often visited
the uh eastern europe then blake had
given them your name
so he betrayed probably 500 plus
of these people to the eastern powers
now he says the kgb assured me these
people wouldn't be killed
come on man i think the kgb did promise
him that because of course
they didn't care what they told him and
so sis reckons about 40 of these people
were killed i mean luckily he
did this after stalin's death and as you
know
the ussr and the eastern countries
generally were much less bloodthirsty
after 53.
yeah and so most of these people were
given long jail sentences etc but about
40 of them are reckoned to have been
killed do you watch problematic content
online of course they do they watch
trigonometry
many isps log your internet activity
and sell that data on to other big tech
companies
or other advertising companies i know
that is why
i use expressvpn to hide my browsing
activities
i bet you do expressvpn is a simple app
which you can have on both your computer
and your smartphone
which hides your traffic into one
channel and directs it through
a vpn server which means your isp can't
see anything that you're doing look the
question
i want to ask no will it slow down the
videos that i watch
definitely not that is one of the
reasons it's been rated as the number
one vpn app by
cnet and wyatt i don't read those
publications because i'm not a nerd
stop handing over your personal data to
isps and big tech companies which are
just gonna use it and sell it on
visit expressvpn.com
trigger that's e x p r
e s s v p
dot trigger i love it when you spell
things out but it gets even better than
that
expressvpn are offering trigonometry
fans three
extra months free go to expressvpn.com
trigger to learn more but look
let's put the counterpoint to this this
is a time of war effectively
now if that had been a british person
being a double agent against the soviets
we'd all
certainly lured him to the skies as a
hero isn't george blake a hero to the
soviets
he is a he was a hero to the soviets
yeah he got the order of lenin from
putin and
blake's very job some of the time was
trying to turn russians and east germans
to get them to spy
for britain so his job was to create
double agents so
so he's creating double agents there
rice and being a double agent here wrong
i mean clearly communism was a
an evil creed i
i i do condemn blake i i'm not trying to
defend him i mean he was in a very
low business of spying and as le carre
says you know horrible things were done
on both sides but that doesn't
that doesn't negate the horrible things
that blake did and the
the many lives that he destroyed did you
ever challenge him on that time and it
sounds like you did talk about it did
you ever put it to him that
the dozens of people at least have died
and hundreds
of people's lives or maybe even
thousands if you include their family
members
would have been ruined by his actions
did he did did you talk to him about
that and did he have any
uh thoughts on that well i raised it
obliquely i mean we were sitting on the
sofa together we were getting on well
and it was a difficult i i i'm not a
kind of very big
hard hitter on the spot so i didn't
really want to say well look mr blake
you killed about 40 people what do you
reckon
so i did say you know you betrayed a lot
of agents
um do you regret anything and then he
talked about regrets he had visibly
breaking up his family you know he was
arrested when his uh
two his three sons were tiny and uh left
his wife behind
he talked about regrets of having
betrayed the sis the british
spying services to which he felt still
loyal he didn't talk
about regrets about agents and when he's
been asked about that when he was asked
about that
at other times he always said none of
these people were killed
and this is the way spying worked you
know uh
you were supposed to catch each other's
agents and if the man who betrayed me to
the british were to walk into this room
now i'd give him a cup of tea
his line was this is just the game and
anyway none of these guys were killed
so i think he genuinely came to believe
that he lived in denial because he was
actually quite a peaceful
bloke he didn't like violence didn't
like killing people he thought all that
was ugly
and so he coped with what he had done by
denying it even to himself
because in many ways he was a picture of
the perfect english gentleman wasn't he
the way he conducted himself
the way he was the one who you know also
he was very very moral
so it's quite incongruous the fact that
the way he presents himself and that's
at the same time being incredibly
duplicitous
i wouldn't say i would say he was the
perfect gentleman but not the perfect
english gentleman
and at sis they always thought he's not
really one of us
i mean he wasn't posh he was a foreigner
he was half jewish
he hadn't been to boarding school and so
he was definitely kind of looked down on
and sneered at
in that way i think that uh if you think
about perfect english gentlemen you're
thinking more of people like philby and
burgess also complete with their
eccentricities
whereas blake was a much more um
straight guy in the way he presented
himself
and so not being a perfect british
gentleman was one of the
issues at work in the in the workplace
and do you think that
contributed in any way to to what then
happened or was it purely an ideological
thing with him he just thought that
communism and marxism and leninism were
the way to go
he just believed in communism i mean a
lot of people especially in britain have
written well he hated britain
he was excluded by the establishment and
therefore he hated britain
now he was excluded by the establishment
but he didn't hate prison at all he
quite liked britain
he just never really had much to do with
brisson because he only spent
i mean the longest stretch of his life
he spent in britain was the five years
he spent in jail before he legged it
so he didn't really spend much of his
life there he admired britain
he was very attached to britain's
wartime record
he um he loved british literature
british films so he and he thought
britain was a very upstanding place and
actually the people who mentored him in
his move to communism
unintentionally were all conservative
members of the british establishment
elizabeth hill who taught him in
cambridge gave him this love of russia
kuru hunts he wrote this theory of
practice of communism book
later his best friend in moscow is
donald mclean another
british tough uh vivian holt the consul
in korea who told him that uh communism
was the future
so he was very um influenced by
conservative
brits from the establishment and he was
rescued from jail we might come to that
by other brits
so i mean he told me at one point look
he said so much of my life has been
given to me by kind british people
he he didn't hate britain at all so
let's move it forward he's doing very
very well in the service
he's doing very very well with the kgb
everything's going swimmingly for him
where did it begin to go wrong well
the problem is always other defectors so
a couple of people from the east
uh two poles leading polish intelligence
officers defected
and this uh double agents in east
germany a kind of
lowly guy called horace eitner
both uh they all point the finger of
suspicion to blake
this guy called golonsky who's um who's
been giving the western powers
information
he defects in 1961
and later he starts to say he's the
grand duke alexei the son of um
charles nicholas ii so he goes a bit
bonkers but before that happens
golonevsky
gives them all the information that they
need to see that the mall that they knew
they had in the service is in fact blake
and so blake at this point has been
because there was already on the
suspicion they didn't want to tell him
this is 1961.
he's been sent to lebanon to learn
arabic in this kind of
british-run school in lebanon called me
cass
and so at one point nicholas elliott
who's the
um mi6 station officer that's there says
to play oh blake you're wanted back in
london i think they want to give you a
promotion
and so blake you know suspects something
but he thinks what can i do you know
i don't want to blow up my family by
escaping to the soviet union now
maybe it's nothing so he flies back to
london
he walks into the offices and james's
and i said what did you feel when you
walked in he said i felt and he says
this in english
the game is up because his uh colleague
uh shergold i think harry shergold says
uh
hello blake um some things to talk about
and let's walk across the park to um
our other office and blake realizes
they're going to the other office so
that they can record an interrogation
and they interrogate him for a couple of
days but they know he's a spy
but they don't have any evidence that
can stand up in court because it's all
secret evidence
they don't want to go to course anyway
be embarrassing and so blake's just
denying everything
i didn't do it i didn't and simon just
to jump in there very briefly when you
say interrogate
they're just asking him questions or are
they applying a bit of the old russian
method
to him not russian at all it's very uh
gentlemanly very collegiate he's
interrogated by three
colleagues who he knows well one of whom
is a good friend
and they're all sitting around and it's
a nice chat
and uh in the evenings he's allowed to
go home to his mother's house in radless
in hertfordshire
so they do take the precaution of
tailing him just in case but every
evening he leaves the interrogation and
he takes the train to
radler where he's not allowed to tell
his mother who's his closest friend in
the world that he's being interrogated
and so on the third day shoguard says
sin well blake you know of course you
spied for them
but you couldn't really help it could
you the koreans tortured you they made
you do it
you didn't have a choice and blake said
burst out and suddenly he says
no nobody tortured me nobody forced me i
spied for the kgb of my own accord
i did it out of belief because he
desperately wants people to see him as
an idealist which he is
and they can't believe it he's given
this kind of unforced confession
given another half hour they said to him
okay you know george get on a plane to
moscow we never want to see you again go
um but they they suddenly have this in
this confession and then he just
confesses the whole thing and he even
stupidly
confesses to the police not realizing
that the confession he'd given to his
sis colleagues wouldn't stand up in
court
he then confesses to the police have you
ever been abroad and felt
out of place because you didn't speak
the language no because i voted brexit
brexit means brexit i know that
sometimes you're abroad you don't speak
the local language it's very awkward
like france is talking to a woman
so you have to shout do you want to
learn another language
i don't for obvious reasons but if you
do
babble is quite simply one of the finest
language learning apps in the business
babel offers a clear and easy to use
interface they have daily 10 to 15
minute lessons
that have been proven effective across
many studies
showing that you can learn up to 14
languages that they offer
so it doesn't matter if you struggle
with language maybe you find it
difficult to pick up or maybe you're
just
english right now babble is offering our
fans
six months free on a six month
subscription with babel
using our special code which is of
course trigger
that's babble b a b b
e l dot co dot u k
slash play and use the promo code
trigger look at that spelling he learned
english on babel
i did but seriously go to babble.com uk
forward slash play use our code trigger
and enjoy babel
and there's that great scene in the book
where he's going to
i think going to make a phone call isn't
he in the park and then there's the
moment of hesitation could you
expand upon that a little bit what
happened there yeah it seems that he
waits outside the telephone booth of
course they tail him on his lunch breaks
so on his lunch break he goes to the
telephone booth and he walks in and then
he walks out again doesn't make the call
and then he goes back in and then he
walks out doesn't make the call
and the suspicion is that he wanted to
call his kgb handler and say look
they got me what should i do because the
kgb had never given him
advice on what to do if caught the line
was well you won't be cause anyway
but and the thing i loved about the book
is that you took the personal which is
the story of blake
but you also expanded it into the
international like the americans
actually who they came across really
well they were very understanding
so in spring 61 the brits called the
americans and say oh
something rather embarrassing has
happened and it's that blake you know
not only um we had various spying
scandals we just had the portland spy
ring blown
burgess maclean but now this bloke play
essentially he's given up every western
agent to the eastern bloc
for eight years now and the americans of
course not happy about this
at all however luckily for the brits the
bay of pigs has just happened
the stir crazy completely
failed american attempt to invade
castro's cuba
using a ragtag bag of cuban exiles
looking a lot like the storming of the
capital but in cuba
a bunch of crazy right-wing nuts trying
to
subvert a government where have we seen
that before so the bay of pigs has gone
completely wrong it's a massive
intelligence disaster
so the americans are not really in a
great position to lecture the brits
the americans do go back and say to each
other never give these idiot brits
any more information again but they
can't afford to really go in hard on the
brits at that particular moment
macmillan the prime minister is hugely
embarrassed macmillan refers to the
um so-called secret services he thinks
his um
spies are a bunch of idiots and are just
there more or less to embarrass him
which is not wrong
no that's interesting so simon he gets
caught
he confesses even to the police not
realizing that he didn't actually need
to
and then he gets sentenced to is it 44
years
42 years uh it seems that the judge had
quite
against all rules had called macmillan
the prime minister
before sentencing and had asked mcmillan
you know this chat blake has he done
much damage
how much damage has he done wow and you
are really not as a judge
in uh in england supposed to discuss
cases under
uh in your court with anyone else and
certainly not with the prime minister
but it appears that this is what justice
parker did and so
he then gives blake 42 years which even
macmillan calls a savage sentence
longest jail sentence in modern british
history
meaning that blake if he served it would
be in jail till 2003.
wow wow and i mean that caused the stir
primarily as well because he was working
for mi6 and mi6 no one even knew that it
existed
you weren't allowed to publicize talk
about it the wider population didn't
know
wasn't there i i loved the bit where
macmillan was almost trying
considering whether just to hush it up
because it was more embarrassment than
it was worth
yeah mcmillan's analogy says when my
gamekeeper catches a fox he doesn't
doesn't string it up in the front room
that's a great line and so yeah
macmillan
thought all this should be secret we
should not be having these trials which
are
in public inevitably and dick white who
is head of sis
said no um you know blake has done these
terrible things
we're going to make an example of him
now of course they didn't make an
example of
the posh spies so philby was under
suspicion at this point but he had been
allowed to go to beirut to work as a
newspaper correspondent
and anthony blunt was uh was
actually became keeper of the queen's
pictures
and john cancross who would later make
two confessions of being a
kgb spy was allowed to return to britain
in old age and die happily in a village
in wheelchair
so they only made an example of blake
they didn't make an example of the um
of the toughs i know it's a very russian
question for me to ask but do you think
there was ever
any consideration of just him you know
you know i don't know if they
had the same technology that we do now
but you know having a cup of tea
or going for a walk and you know having
a little heart attack or anything like
that
there was discussion i mean they had
this uh weekend after
blake's confession the interrogators say
okay
shergold says let's all go to my cottage
in
surrey i think and we'll have a weekend
then we'll talk
about this together so blake is there
and shogul's mother and blake make
pancakes in the kitchen for everyone and
it's all quite jolly
but meanwhile the mi6 people are having
this conversation of can we bump him off
it would
save us a lot of embarrassment in the
end this is decided that this is not
appropriate and do you know why was that
just not
the done thing at the time or did they
have some particular
reason to think that way i think mi6
probably didn't want to start bumping
off
british citizens in britain there might
have been pesky questions from the
opposition benches etc
i'm guessing that that would have been a
consideration
and britain you know for all its faults
prison is a democracy
and there is scrutiny of this kind of
stuff so although one would like to draw
the analogy with the ussr as you do
there are important differences yeah
well this is why i just to finish this
point uh
this is why i'm curious whether how
seriously you take blake's denial of the
agents that he betrayed being killed
because
if in his mind well look what i've done
and no one did anything to me
why would the kgb be killing off these
telephone operators or whatever
do you think he just you know that's why
he didn't believe that the spies he
betrayed had been killed
i mean blake had seen a lot of violence
in his life
you know he had been in the resistance
he had been in post-war occupied germany
where he had to deal with a lot of
former nazis in the german navy
he had been in korea where he'd seen
american airplanes destroying korean
villages where the
half the prisoners he was with died on a
death march
i mean he knew that terrible things were
done in the world he he was not
a blue eyed boy by that point and
the judge sentenced him there were three
years each of four
three concurrent certain sentences
weren't there each of 14 years if memory
serves correctly
he then gets sent to wormwood scrubs
where
he's a bit of a model prisoner isn't he
you like this guy don't you i kind of
did
francis is a big fan he is a model
prisoner i mean in one word trust
finally he doesn't
have to live a secret life because
everyone knows he's aspiring and
communist so for the first time in his
adult life he can just be himself
he's not living underground and he he
becomes an incredibly
likable guy and of course he's one of
the few educated people in the prison so
he
has classes where he teaches these
cockney prisoners german and arabic
and french he reads the quran on a you
know
a book stand made for him by a grateful
fellow prisoner
he writes letters to the authorities on
behalf of his fellow prisoners who can't
write
he's just a great guy everyone in the
prison loves him the screws the wardens
love him too
you know he's he's just a good bloke and
he doesn't complain about being there
for 42 years
and so yeah he becomes the kind of most
popular man in the prison
but meanwhile all the while he's
plotting his escape which isn't very
difficult
escaping from a british prison in the
1960s seems to have been a
you know bit of a cinch and how does
that happen
he identifies this irishman who's about
to be released sean burke so burke's
going to be on the outside burke is
quite clever
and burke hates britain so burke agrees
to help him escape
they get money from former peace
activists who've also been in jail with
them
and um it's really quite amateurish a
burglar breaks a window
so that blake can make it to the outside
wall of the scrubs
burke throws a roof a rope ladder up to
up on top of the wall
forgets to tie it there's nothing to tie
it with so then blake has to jump off
the wall
it's about a four meter five meters jump
off the wall of wrong one would scrub so
he's quite badly hurt breaks his wrist
but anyway bert shoves him in a car and
a few minutes later they're hiding in a
bedsit
a couple of hundred meters away on high
lever road in shepherd's bush
and it really really was that simple
wasn't it i mean you would have thought
that
a prisoner like blake you know somebody
who is a traitor
possibly one of britain's most how co
heinous traitors wouldn't why didn't
they put him under armed guard all the
rest of it
i think partly because he put them off
gulf guard by being such a nice bloke
and partly because i mean british
prisoners escaped that's what they did
the great train robbers two of them
escaped i mean remember ronnie biggs
ending up in brazil
also at about that time at one point
about
just after blake escaped 10 prisoners
escaped from one with scrubs in a month
including this bloke known as frankie
the mad axeman
who began writing letters to the
newspapers so
frankie the mad axe man
mate if you're gonna go into crime you
need a nickname you need a good name
you need it it's all about the good name
in there yeah i mean there was also mad
frankie fraser i mean
there's lots of mad frankie's so anyway
he escaped
how did he actually get to the ussr
considering
he's got the police and mi6 on his tail
now
well and burke who he's hiding with
burke is actually a writer an artist
he's also a you know small-time crook
but burke thinks right this escape of
george blake i'm going to write the book
of my life about it which he does the
springing of george blake it's great
book
and so burke needs it to be known by the
police
that he did it so burke starts writing
letters to the police about
starts calling the police tells them
where they find the getaway car so it's
becoming a real problem
meanwhile burke and blake are hiding in
a hampstead flat
with pat pottle who is a peace activist
an anti-bomb activist who'd been jailed
for
trespassing on an american air base and
uh
so he was helping blake and so he's
hiding in hampstead
how are we going to get them out so they
build a camper van in a camper van they
build a secret compartment
and a peace activist named michael
randall takes his wife and two young
sons
on holiday to germany at christmas
and blake is hidden in the secret
compartments at the bottom of the
campervan
they leave britain they go from dover to
cali nobody checks them it's plain
sailing
and blake is in west berlin he walks to
an east berlin border post
and demands to speak to somebody from
the soviet command
[Music]
so the soviets weren't actually the ones
that broke him out they didn't help him
get to berlin it was just
through connections and friends etc and
and how was he treated when
when he he gets to to that checkpoint
the german guard is not very forthcoming
but eventually blake is given a bed
while phone calls are made
and luckily blake's former kgb handler
sergey kondrachev
is in berlin and they find kondrachev
and they say there's this bloke here he
might be
blake kondracev rushes to the border
post and he and blake embrace and become
firm friends for the next 40 years of
their lives in moscow
where blake is swiftly taken to and
until congress and blake attends
concepts funeral
and so yeah he he gets lucky
so he gets to this place he gets to the
ussr which is
in many ways the embodiment of his dream
ever you know
he he's a firm and a vowed communist
does it live up to his expectations
within a week he knew that communism had
failed
it doesn't take long
[Laughter]
can you imagine being that guy you spent
your life you betrayed hundreds of
people
for this ideal and you get there and
it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
they all had that experience guy burgess
said that um
the soviet union was like glasgow on a
saturday night in the 19th century
which i think is the best description
i've read yeah and
um yeah so it's very ramshackle it's run
down blake has given a nice flat
because you know he's kgb but he he has
his plan he wants to drive through the
soviet union and admire its different
regions
and then he discovers the state of
soviet roads etc etc so he's very
downcast and of course the soviets think
that he's a
triple agent that he has already been
turned by the british
so they're not going to give him any
responsible work and so yeah it's very
miserable but then thankfully the best
thing happens to him his mother his
dutch mother
comes to live with him in moscow and
that cheers him up immensely then he
meets a russian woman ida who he marries
so the thing about blake the difference
between him and philby is philby was a
brit
philby in moscow you know yearned for
britain he'd read the times do the times
crossword he'd listen to the cricket
he has this great description of
listening to arsenal win the fa cup
final in 1971.
he lived emotionally in britain but
blake was gaza politician he spoke very
good russian
and his view was i'm just going to make
this work and he did he
he integrated he becomes russian which
maclean does as well really
and do you think he ever regretted it
he in terms of once he got there he
realized that communism
wasn't going to work he realized he was
fighting on the wrong side
or did he believe in what he did he
didn't believe in what he did anymore i
mean he believed that communism was a
beautiful ideal
and for him that mattered so he could
see that the reality was awful
but he thought well it's a great ideal
so you know it's not
such a bad thing that i've given my life
to it but also
because he was a determinist because he
thought everything was predetermined
there is some kind of force
maybe not god but some force that makes
us do what we do
there's no point he thought having
regrets or um
thinking things might have been
different they couldn't have been
different so
he just copes with life as it's thrown
at him
and you know he'd been everywhere and
he'd always coped he'd been in cairo
he'd been in a korean prison
he'd been in uh post-war germany he he
always managed to find his feet and in
that way that that's very admirable
absolutely and then of course the fall
of communism what was blake's opinions
of that it sounds as if
he thought it was an evidence an
inevitability
yeah he did i mean he thought you know
given that communism delivered a
terrible life to people it was not going
to survive
and yeah it was quite traumatic because
he you know he'd seen the british empire
collapse and then the soviet empire and
he'd left his
his homeland the netherlands he'd lost
kind of three homelands as it were
um but he you know he he believed in
communism with a human face that kind of
fantasy that
from duke check into the 80s and he
thought gorbachev was that and he was
quite excited about gorbachev and
yeltsin initially
but yeah when the soviet union collapses
i mean he he copes he's cope with
everything by this point he's he's what
he's over 70
and he he just plugs on that's really
interesting and simon
uh i we wanted to talk to you a little
bit about some of the sort of lessons
and implications but
the first thing i wanted to ask you is
he was obviously
and not an ordinary person just by
virtue of his
life and biography was there anything in
particular that struck you about him
when you met him when you talked to him
what struck me he could listen
it's a very rare gift i mean as a i know
i'm banging on now but
it's something you learn as a journalist
you learn to listen to people
because often the thing that you want to
hear is not the thing that they're
trying to tell you they're trying to
tell you something more
interesting journalists can listen
diplomats psychologists
and spies and he writes about this
somewhere that
if you just listen the other person will
happily tell you everything
and so that made him very likable um
i also recognized in him the
cosmopolitism that i have
and so when people call blake a traitor
which i do as well in the title of my
book i mean he was a traitor to britain
but he didn't feel like a traitor
because he felt like he was a man of the
world not a man of britain
and it didn't mean he hated britain it's
just that he he felt himself
to be largely above nation so and that
kind of
adaptability uh which i think we
cosmopolitans have i mean you probably
recognize it yourself as well constance
and that when you come into a new
environment
you're trying to sniff out the codes the
rules
so i you know i live in paris and you
learn that in paris when you greet
people you don't smile
whereas in the u.s when you greet people
you do smile so these little things
so i recognized a lot of the kind of
cosmopolitan ticks
that he had and yeah in a sense
a lot of the spy literature in britain
is about british gentleman you know from
james bond to philby
and this is a book about a cosmopolitan
spy
and the the thing that i found very very
interesting
is because how everybody seems to keep
falling in love
with the myth of communism and it's only
when they're confronted by the realities
of it
does it seem to be this moment where
they realize it doesn't work
why is it we keep falling for the myth
i think in the case of blake it's
because he had grown up with the
religious idea of paradise
it was very important to him that there
should be a paradise
and clearly one's own society is never
paradise so paradise must be somewhere
else
and then communism gives a
very convincing picture in a way of
paradise
you know communist literature marx
and so he needed paradise which
i don't feel the need of i mean i always
think as a liberal
i think what we should try for is the
least bad society
but in these kind of um i think probably
in most religions suddenly in islam and
christianity less so in judaism judaism
is not big on paradise but islam and
christianity are very big on them
that is this central idea that life on
earth is horrible and you know
these books are risen at times when
people die young and everyone around you
dies and um
it's dreadful but there is paradise and
so i think
communism the need for communism is the
need for paradise
that's really interesting point and do
you think that
is part of of the distinction there
because
you talk about the least bad society
which is
a view vision i share as well uh
accepting the reality that
a perfect society is not going to be
possible it's not very inspiring though
is it it doesn't
doesn't sell right it doesn't sell very
well where's the idea as you say of
paradise or utopia or whatever word you
want to
use to describe it that sells very well
that that's that's exciting that's
invigorating it's convincing it's
persuasive uh it's something that you
want to sign up to
you saw that now that we're talking
about modernity in the brexit referendum
where the brexiteers are promising a
kind of paradise
a return to the best of britain the the
golden age
and remainers are offering the least bad
option
you know nobody would pretend that life
in britain in 2016 was paradise
but remain and say you know this is
about as good as we can make it and
you're right it's not a very
it's not a great sell i mean it is to me
and i think it is to me partly because
you know my family's from south africa
so i've seen a society that is totally
dysfunctional that is just awful
and i would go from the netherlands as a
child in the 70s and 80s
to visit south africa and come back to
the netherlands and think
you know netherlands is not paradise but
it's pretty damn good
um this is about and it was it was about
and it still is about the least bad
society on earth
so i've seen a a society that's really
not bad
and i've seen a terrible dysfunctional
evil society
so i know which one i would choose and
we've just we've seen a resurgence
in especially the young people very much
advocating communism believing in
communism saying
you know the classic thing communism has
never been tried
why is it that this is so popular
amongst that generation
i don't know i don't hear that i i see
that young americans are talking about
socialism but i think that by that they
mean
denmark they mean universal healthcare
and free college i i don't think they
mean nationalization of all production
and raw by a politburo and gulags
i mean francis i'd forgotten of course
that you also have an international
background from venezuela
i don't sound it i know
[Laughter]
you sound like you're very much against
any sort of diversity really
and i think that one of the difficult i
mean the difficulty with the word
socialism is it conflates let's say
denmark with venezuela
and so it's used by the american right
well if you want socialism you want
venezuela
i i don't i don't see among
i also don't see politically movements
succeeding
that are saying um let's let's have
communism let's have the ussr
no no there aren't although there
certainly are
people who are uh advocating for
communism i agree with you they're
probably a fringe
i mean the counter argument to that
might be that uh
you know when soviet union was created
nobody was saying anything about
uh the purges and the gulags and the
poly bureau or anything like that either
it was all about
fairness equality justice for workers
and
and uh peasants at the at the time uh
but it's i guess your more interesting
question might be rather than getting
into the nuances of politics
um the the sort of what happens when
people pursue very idealistic visions of
of the world as opposed to dealing with
with reality i wonder whether
you know your conversations with george
blake and research for the book give you
an insight into
the sort of maybe preconditions that
encourage people to think in those ways
i mean blake himself said there is no
idealism anymore you know he complains
about that at one point he says well you
know in my day people spied out of
idealism but now people only spy out of
base motives you have to pay the money
and
i mean for
not for 70 years but for several decades
there was this political paradise on
offer
this rhetorical paradise
from before the russian revolution but
let's say
until the 60s 70s there are quite a lot
of people who are falling for it
by the time i was a teenager in the 80s
i don't really think anyone was anymore
so it had run its course and i sometimes
wonder if i had been a teenager in the
30s
you know as my grandmother did would i
have become a communist she
she did she said she stopped with the
nazi soviet pact i don't know
but um maybe i mean
it was a paradise on offer in the 30s at
a time
when the capitalist powers were refusing
to do anything about fascism
so that might be a moment i mean blake
became a communist in 1950 by which time
we really did know about stalin's purges
if you can to pay attention
so that by then by then by 1950
communism is going out of fashion
but at the same time communism is
conquering it's conquered eastern europe
it's conquering china
so it's kind of winning having already
gone out of fashion so i think
me and you guys are younger we've grown
up in a time
when there hasn't really been a paradise
on offer and in a sense i think that's
been lucky for us because it saved us
from
diving into millenarian movements
i mean trump is offering a version of
that brexit but those seem to appeal
mostly to old people
that's really interesting and simon what
lessons do you think can be learnt from
the life of george blake
don't be an idealist don't don't fall
for some dream of
some country that you don't know about
and some system that has never been
successfully
done just go with what works uh
don't i mean my favorite election slogan
was um
conrad adenauer the german chancellor in
the 50s
at one point campaigns under the slogan
kind of experimenter
no experiments which i i have to say i
am
[Music]
as an anti-idealist i share yeah oh it's
interesting oh
i i feel like you're very much in your
place but in terms of being in paris and
not smiling when you greet people you
have that sort of
very reserved demeanor but uh listen
simon it's been great chatting to you
the book
not only is a very interesting story but
it's incredibly well written
uh and you know your experience and your
writing skills really shine through so
uh it's out on the fourth of february is
that fourth
yeah yeah for february happy traitor
happy traitor and we really recommend
everybody
reads it uh but before uh we let you go
we've got one final question for you
which is always what's the one thing
we're not talking about but we really
should be
modern spying hacking i mean
in blake's day it was very hard to get
any information on what the other side
was doing
and now i mean the russians probably
know more about the us government than
most people in the trump cabinet
simon thank you so much um if people
want to find you online where's the best
way to be
uh to do that uh look for me on twitter
it's cooper simon is my twitter handle
and i'll be tweeting about the happy
traitor obsessively
promoting this book um to death it's
worth promoting but hopefully not to
your own death at least
but simon thanks so much for coming on
the show we really appreciate your time
we recommend everybody gets the happy
traitor
and we will of course see you very soon
with another brilliant interview like
this one
or a live stream all of them go out at
7pm uk time
take care and see you soon guys we hope
you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button
so that you never miss another fantastic
episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below